of course we heard from some protesters
earlier there's also a set of protesters
in michigan
videos went viral yesterday of angry
people gathered together shouting stop
the count
stop the count it really unnerved me
until i
actually watched the footage and now
well i hate to say it i kind of agree
with them
okay you guys give me a chance right and
try to make a living
okay okay uh my last victim
she was very heavy in the body okay uh
so heavy her blood type was marinara
marinara sauce a thick sauce
nothing wow okay you guys
i just flew in i did i'm not tired i
never get tired nor will i die
wow you guys are tough here's my
impression of al pacino
if he were what yes a vampire
there's only two things i can't resist
the taste of human blood
and a great figure subbler hubla
nothing wow okay that killed in
transylvania so
you see the sun out because i'm dying up
here
see there's two kinds of count counting
the vote and then
you know dracula
[Laughter]
i apologize a lot of strain a lot of
stress